when the history of russia's war in
ukraine is written
remember this name
as of style
ukrainian troops have endured russian
bombardments at the vast steel works for
weeks as most of the rest of mariupol
city fell
the bloody standoff has been likened to
the brutal world war ii battle of
stalingrad when soviet forces ultimately
held out against nazi invaders
though at the other style steel plant
its defenders are still under fire under
siege and under no illusion about the
peril
green
with the overwhelming forces of the
enemy
and damn it they show such endurance and
heroism that the whole of ukraine must
know what it means to be faithful
the more than four square miles of the
azov style steel works have become a
symbol of that endurance
built in the 1930s with a network of
underground bunkers and tunnels you
almost couldn't have designed a better
fortress if you tried
it's why russia's much larger military
has failed to defeat some 2 000
ukrainian fighters holed up inside
despite being told to encircle it so a
fly can't get through
satellite imagery gives a sense of
russia's plan of attack
using artillery and airstrikes to hit
supply lines and ukrainian positions
rather than risk sending in ground
troops
a rail depot and mill can be seen here
on the 9th of april
they look to be intact
but almost 3 weeks later the area is
destroyed
here a second mill
also by the 29th of april it's gone
though given the depth of the tunnels
and strength of the bunkers under this
plant ukrainian defenders can withstand
almost anything russia drops
as well as the military's last stand
this place became the last hope for
hundreds of civilians
they sought refuge underground only to
find themselves in the eye of the storm
with dwindling food water and medical
supplies
lena lives in the capital kiev but her
son is a fighter defending the avastyl
plant
every morning bogdan texts her a plus
sign from his phone to signal he's still
alive
hundreds of soldiers are wounded and
stuck underground there
as a mother i am rooting for azov
this hurts
this hurts for every mother
this can't be told
again it's like i bleed every day blood
blood blood
i can't breathe i can't sleep
every day he is in my head the last
defenders of mario paul are seen as
heroes in ukraine whatever happens next
because they drew russian fire onto them
for weeks messing up moscow's invasion
plans
mayor of the city still hopes everyone
can be saved
there is a military way which has the
name operation extraction which might
free our brave warriors from this
fortress and they could leave with
weapons in hand and continue to protect
our country
it's a difficult thing so negotiations
at high levels continue
more western weapons would also make a
difference
possibly enabling a
counter-attack one thing's for sure
as long as ukrainian fighters remain at
these steel works they're stopping
vladimir putin from declaring victory
over the whole of mario paul
and that matters
debra haynes sky news keeve